Russian doll was the surprise hit of
January and the show seemed to come out
of nowhere to sweep the board as the
best program of the month whilst the
whole thing ended perfectly and that
probably isn't a need for a follow-up we
all know deep down that Netflix won't
let this one go off into the parade and
that they'll have plans for a sequel
obviously hype is quite high for its
return and with Natasha Lian admitting
that it was originally pitched as a
three season show it seems very likely
but what direction will the show take
and when can we expect its release well
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the potential second season of
Russian doll as well as what I think
will happen in it there will be some
spoilers here in regards to the first
season so if you don't want to know
anything about it then I highly suggest
that you turn off now but without the
way I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to ok so firstly if this show is
renewed then I imagine that it will have
a release of January 2020 to coincide
with the annual schedule that Netflix
tends to stick to you can tell by the
promotion on the app that they already
know what kind of hit they have on their
hands so I imagine that they've already
got the second season script done and
they'll begin shooting in the summer as
the seasons are just 8 half-hour
episodes this makes it far easier in
terms of shooting and editing especially
with the reuse of locations so if we're
lucky we may even get it just in time
for Christmas obviously the next big
thing that most people want to know is
what could happen in the second season
well there's a couple of different
scenarios that I've fleshed out similar
to how Nadia would to see all possible
outcomes we could get the first
direction that the show could take comes
from your opinion of the ending if you
think that the timelines merged then the
first question is what timeline are they
in are they in Alan's versions of the
events or Nadia's if it's the former
then the second season will most likely
take the perspective of Alan and flesh
out his full backstory as Nadia has
already had that if it's the latter then
it could showcase more of Nadia's past
beyond the glimpses that we got just
opposing this if you think that the
timelines didn't merge
we will have an offshoot of both
versions of the couple's of going off
down their own paths this would be
interesting as it could showcase perhaps
one successful relationship and one
failing one all based on a single moment
say similar to sliding doors this would
definitely be extremely interesting to
watch but it also may be very difficult
for the creators to juggle as
convolution could be a big enemy here
the third possibility comes from the
line that Noddy essays in the show that
states there may be an infinite amount
of timelines as Nadia and Alan have
already had their happy ending we could
follow one of the timelines why they
never met and see just how different
their lives could have been without each
other who knows they may even come
together at the end but this does seem
like a slight retread and it would sort
of put the viewers in their own time
loop so I can't imagine this being the
case another possibility and the one
that opens up the most amount of options
is if the show completely scraps Nadia
and Alan and starts with brand-new
characters who find themselves stuck in
a time loop the actors could easily
return to the show and play different
people similar to what we see in
American Horror Story and this would
allow for a new setting and scenarios
personally I think that this would be
the best way to go as I said earlier
Nadia and Alan have already had their
perfect send-off and I would rather see
a new group of people figuring
themselves out rather than ones who've
already gained closure obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the second
season and what you think could happen
in it make sure you leave them in the
comments below and check out my
breakdown of the show's ending which
will be linked after this video if you
missed yesterday's video on the plot
recap of this year's other timely
franchise happy deathday then don't
worry because they'll be linked at the
end this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]